we're learning that just a short time
ago an Iranian drone an unmanned
aircraft came within 100 feet of a US
Navy f-18 fighter jet in the Persian
Gulf this f-18 was in a pattern
attempting to land on board the carrier
Nimitz in the Persian Gulf the Iranian
drone came within 100 feet of the f-18
it did have to take evasive action to
maneuver to get out of the way of the
drone the US military used an emergency
frequency channel to try and radio the
Iranians they believed or operating that
drone no response from them the drone
eventually did move away but this again
today underscores the growing concern
about the possibility of miscalculation
in the Persian Gulf between US forces
and Iranian forces Barbara before you go
is this it is a first certainly a first
time hearing of an incident like this
well actually it isn't back in 2016 the
Iranians also they do fly their drones
over the Gulf but because there is so
that there was a similar incident but
because there's so much aircraft
activity over the Gulf military aircraft
commercial airplanes it is a very
heavily trafficked airspace there is
always the concern about miscalculation
being able to reach whoever's operating
drones and make sure that there is not a
catastrophe